all right let's go to max
in philadelphia pennsylvania max how are
we doing this afternoon
hey fellas how are you thanks for taking
the time you betcha how can we help
brother
yeah um so i wanna i've never really
done anything like
this before so i wanna make sure i ask
this in the best way possible
um i made a huge mistake in going to
boston university for school
um between bentley and bu uh
i took about 250 thousand dollars of
student loans
okay for an education degree that i'm
not using i'm not teaching
um i'm working you know i'm looking at a
bank i'm lucky to be employed but uh
the 207 000 of that is in default um
my payment was supposed to be twenty two
hundred dollars a month uh i make 50 a
year i just simply don't make it
enough to make that kind of payment um
so i guess i'm wondering especially
during these circumstances where you
know i hear dave talk about being as
gazelle i'm trying to take this
and take care of this as quickly as
possible uh i was driving uber
i was you know i play piano part-time
and you know for the better part of a
year i guess it'll be a year next month
like
all of that has been completely
decimated and who knows when it
might come back um i guess i will say on
top of that like the uber thing
i got into a car accident a few months
ago and got a concussion so
cars go on for now too um so i guess
one what are these i mean in your
experience have you or have you heard
any stories about what these creditors
actually do
i i mean i'm paying them 400 a month but
obviously that's a drop in the budget
and it's kind of a nightmare scenario
yeah
you're not making spawner and you're not
making a dent in it at all
uh max yeah and right now uh you need a
bigger shovel
right okay okay um do we need to get
your income
up uh because you're not going to be
able to pay
it off uh making 55 thousand dollars 58
000
a year we we need to get your income up
all right
um especially with 400 of my payments so
what
what's your career right now uh i work
at a bank
in finance all right what did you go to
school for
elementary education okay all right so
yeah
why they approved that you know 250 000
is beyond me
hey hold on hold on though max hold on
let's don't do that yeah okay
let's take full ownership of where we're
at okay yeah you signed it bro
i mean and it's yeah yeah you're normal
you know what i'm saying you're you're
normal i i signed for student loans i
did too
john so i mean we're not it was the
stupidest thing i've ever done well i
mean
we've all done we all been there so
let's put that down and let's move on to
solving the problem now right
yeah so sounds good all right so you're
making 58 000
a year in the banking institution all
right you said you cannot drive for uber
what else can you do so you have an
education
um can you go home and tutor online
right now
especially within your age bracket max
you can you can jump online
and do some creative things to generate
some income
all right right now you need to step
back and and
have a game plan how are you going to
generate another 25 000
a year because check this out if you
could generate another 25 000
a year you can attack this debt and be
debt free within the next three to four
years uh because i'm going to show you
how to pretty much negotiate
i'm going to give you access to my book
to show your student loan that i want so
when we hang up once you stay on the
line kelly's going to send you that book
for free
on john and i it's really on me because
it's my book but i love john
i'm happy to take credit yeah yeah but
i'm going to show you how to refi it
how to get it out of collections how to
refi it and how to come up with creative
ways to negotiate
some type of uh settlement offers within
this thing now you may not be able to
settle it i'm not saying you will be but
you might be able to
but the key thing for you right now is
uh making your your shovel larger as far
as in getting your income so that's what
we're gonna do we're gonna give you two
books
uh actually i'm gonna give you two books
i'm gonna give you one book and i'm
gonna tell you
you need to go listen to our good friend
ken coleman we call him the shovel guy
okay because he's gonna show you how to
turn his 58 000
and maybe turn it into a hundred
thousand dollars because he's a
pro at teaching people how to make more
money how to get into their sweet spot
so you have a shovel problem and then
from there you need to go ahead and get
gazelle intense and i'm gonna show you
how to take that shovel
and get out of debt you failed me yeah
yeah so we really can't lay out too much
for you right now but the key thing is
you got to get on a clear budget you for
the next three to five years max you are
broke
okay you don't have time to are you
single are you married
i'm actually getting married to december
you get married in december
okay how much debt does she have
uh i as far as i know zero as far as you
know you ain't talking too fast
you know you're getting married have
that conversation today max
you propose without knowing it certainly
doesn't doesn't have the
uh student loan issue that i do oh yeah
but she may got she may have carlos she
may have something
yeah well no no carl okay cool well just
ask her
you know ask her do you have any debt
outside of a mortgage you know just
just ask her you know and they said now
that's now that just brings up another
thing right there
right you know two incomes you have two
incomes attacking his debt
you can go out there and generate some
more what does she do for a living
uh she works for the uh the state of
jersey right now
oh so she's making pretty decent money
now with some good benefits
uh yeah they're doing all right i mean
she's only working one day a week
uh i i don't know something about them
not being able to distribute laptops for
last year which is a little ridiculous
but
well she's going into the office one day
a week but is she working from home
no i i mean i don't know what their team
came up with
but yeah basically they're going into
the office one day a week and that's it
for now until this kind of calms down i
that's beyond me i haven't
all right so hey hey max about it hey
max it's something i'm picking up in
your soul a little bit
that just to cut through it okay in your
original question you asked us
what are the creditors really going to
do and behind that is
yeah this sense of you you feel guilty
that you signed a piece of paper
and that that waffles back and forth
between blaming the folks who let you
sign it which is fair
and feeling stupid and ashamed that you
did what you did
i want you to think of that guilt and
that shame as a big cinder block
you are not going to get anywhere in a
in a new marriage you're not going to
get
anywhere towards paying down this debt
which brother you owe
until you put that cinder black cinder
block down
pick up a shovel two of them three of
them yes
you you got wiped out in 2020. it sucks
now you got a choice to make brother are
you gonna sit there and go what are they
really gonna do they're gonna come get
me
or you're gonna get back up be the be
the
the the husband that your new wife is
gonna deserve
and need and that she is marrying into
and then brother
go pay off your debt stay on the line
anthony's gonna give you his book and
you're going to call us back in a year
and we're going to show you you're going
to tell us how far you've wiped this
sucker down
because you're on it this is the dave
ramsey show